*Silence très sonore*
... Je ne sais pas quoi faire.
Alors pourquoi ne pas faire une intro normale en vous expliquant ce qu'il va se passer dans cette vidéo.
Nous sommes sur "Block'Hood".
"Block'Hood" qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est un jeu dans lequel on va créer notre propre écosystème.
C'est-à-dire qu'on va créer un espace
d'ailleurs assez vertical parce que la surface au sol est limitée.
Un espace qui va s'auto-suffire.
C'est-à-dire qu'on produira tout ce qu'il faut pour que les gens soient bien
que ça soit des trucs physiques ou des trucs pas physiques.
Je propose tout simplement de lancer une partie
en bac à sable, en mode écologie.
Je vais vous expliquer
c'est ouf ! (x2)
J'adore, j'adore ce jeu !
Donc on commence on est là.
Il y a 4 types de constructions :
Il y a les espaces publics,
qui vont créer, du coup, une communauté
qui vont créer euh..de..de..de..des interactions entre les gens.
Il y a des espaces de production
qui vont permettre de produire tout ce qui est électricité,
eau, euh.. engrais s'il y a besoin d'engrais, tout ça.
Il y a les bâtiments
qui vont permettre que,
bah des gens..emménagent ici tout simplement.
Et si des gens emménagent, ça crée quoi ?
ça crée du travail, ça crée de.. de la consommation,
voilà tout ça.
Et ici ce sont les blocs organiques
c'est-à-dire les blocs qui vont créer, euh... du bien-être pour les habitants.
En cliquant ici, "Panneau des ressources",
on voit l'état des ressources de son "Hood"
Son "Hood" c'est en gros sa ville.
Actuellement par exemple, on est à 150 dollars
et on a 1000 points d'eau souterraine.
On ne consomme pas, on ne perd pas, mais on ne gagne pas non plus : on est à zéro.
Je vous propose pour commencer par mettre en place un sol.
Hop (x4), voilà.
Comme vous pouvez le voir ici, l'indicateur nous montre qu'on est en train de gagner, en eau souterraine.
Voilà c'est juste un truc qui produit de l'eau souterraine,
et c'est très bien comme ça.
Pour vivre il nous faut quoi ?
Il nous faut de l'électricité.
Mais l'électricité, par exemple dans les centrales pour la faire, il faut de l'uranium hein.
Ça, ça nous va pas.
Nous ce qu'on veut, c'est de l'électricité sans qu'il y ait besoin de rien pour la produire.
Le panneau solaire !
Et oui vous le connaissez tous !
On va se faire une rangée de panneaux solaires ici.
Hop (x3), voilà.
Panneau solaire, ça va nous créer un maximum d'électricité.
Dans votre corps, il y a quoi majoritairement ?
De l'eau, l'eau c'est la vie.
Et cette imitation de Jhon Rachid qui imite Van Damme est nulle.
Ça c'est pas la vie.
On va donc construire des châteaux d'eau qui vont produire de l'eau.
Ces châteaux d'eau, par contre, vont nous coûter régulièrement de l'argent, 2 dollars par mois.
5 châteaux d'eau = ton abonnement Netflix, c'est terrible !
On va quand même en mettre trois... C'est la famille.
Donc là, comme vous pouvez le voir, notre indicateur est vert partout sauf en argent.
Bien sûr parce qu'on paye pour ces châteaux d'eau
et on a rien qui rapporte de l'argent.
Du coup je propose que des gens viennent habiter là.
Mais pour que les gens viennent habiter, il nous faut de l'air frais et des belles choses.
Et l'air frais et ces belles choses, ce sont les palmiers qu'il faut mieux les donner.
Qui n'a jamais rêvé d'avoir des palmiers ?
Voilà. Maintenant qu'il y a un peu d'air frais et une belle vue sur les palmiers,
qu'il y a autre chose que ces panneaux solaires en gros,
on va pouvoir commencer à mettre des appartements.
Et des gens vont venir habiter ici.
Et bien évidemment avec ceci pour générer de l'argent,
où t'achètes ta bouteille de vodka le samedi soir quand Intermarché est fermé ?
A l'épicerie du coin !
Et là on va commencer à faire, de l'argent des abonnés.
*Clap* (x4)
Et là ça nous fait plaisir ! (*en applaudissant toujours*)
3 appartements ici, 2 épiceries, franchement on est bien, on est archi-bien.
Maintenant ce qu'il va falloir mettre, c'est des passages
pour que gens puissent atteindre les épiceries etc..
*Construction des passages*
Pourquoi on ne pas y accéder ? Je ne comprends pas là.
Mais c'est pour ça qu'on fait faillite, les mecs n'accèdent pas aux épiceries.
Mais pourquoi !? Il y a un chemin là !
Nan j'ai fait de la m**de là.
*Supprime sa partie*
*incompréhensible*
Euh... Pardon !
*Rires*
En faite c'est le sol de m**de là que j'ai mis là
qui crée de l'eau souterraine.
En faite, il faut que je le mette juste
Tu sais quoi ? On va faire une tour de sol.
Voilà, comme ça on n'en parle plus.
Voilà, c'est très moche, je m'en bats les c**illes
*Rires*
Je reprends !
L' électricité.
*Reconstruit la rangée de panneaux solaires*
Le grand air.
*Reconstruit les arbres*
L'eau.
*Reconstruit les châteaux d'eau*
Les habitants.
*Reconstruit les appartements*
Les épiceries.
*Reconstruit les épiceries*
Tada ! La ville est enfin prête !
J'ai un peu galéré parce que
en gros, il faut bien doser entre..
combien de ressources il y a euh... pour pour combien d'habitants
et combien d'habitants pour combien d'épiceries.
Voilà, s'il y a trop de commerces et pas assez d'habitants
Les gens achètent pas, consomment pas : l'épicerie elle ferme.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, on est dans le rouge en eau souterraine hein.
Merci, euh.. la tour euh... d'eau souterraine.
*Rires*
ça c'est le pire truc que j'ai fait de ma vie. C'est tout simplement honteux !
En consommateur, on en a toujours pas assez
donc ce que je propose c'est de faire des maisons avec étages.
On peut tout simplement ajouter un appartement ici, et aussi ici.
Et en fait, on va juste construire un ascenseur pour qu'ils puissent accéder à leur appartement.
On met l'ascenseur là et on en remet un au-dessus.
Hop ! Sauf que là il va falloir commencer à faire un étage.
Tac ! (x4)
Tout ça va bien évidemment tenir hein ?
*Souffle du nez fortement*
Qu'est-ce qui prend de la thune là ? Je comprends pas.
C'est juste ça !? C'est juste ces trucs-là qui prennent autant de thune, les châteaux d'eau ?
*...* Si j'en dégage un ?
Attention, on a, on va peut être vu la 1ère immense sécheresse de France.
Et bah non c'est bon !
Et là du coup on gagne presque assez de thune mais pourquoi on n'en a pas assez p**ain !?
On est toujours dans le négatif c'est insupportable voyons !
Oh !! On va faire un bar !
Oh mon Dieu ! Tout ce que ça donne comme thune, on va faire un bar.
Faut de la bière, pour faire de la bière, ok j'ai compris.
Il faut du blé, champ de blé.
Popinn !!
On en met 2.
Incroyable !
La brasserie, qui va se mettre à créer de la bière. On va en faire 2.
On fait péter le bar !
ON EST RICHE !!!!
Bon le seul 'blème c'est que tout est dégueulasse. Comment je réaménage cette m**de ?
Faut faire un 2ème étage.
Désolé le 1er étage c'était la.. la bêta. C'était l'alpha test, désolé les gars.
Hop ! (x2)
Super ! On fait une 2ème brasserie.
Je ne peux pas mettre de champ là-dessus. Pourquoi !?
Mais nan !
Ouais, je ne peux pas mettre de l'arbre en hauteur c'est interdit.
On n'a pas le droit de mettre de l'arbre en hauteur.
Ah ! Je sais où on peut le mettre !
En haut de la tour d'eau souterraine.
*Rires*
*Tape sur son bureau*
Génial ! Attends est-ce que je peux "carotte" le jeu en faisant ça ?
*Place les blocs en lévitation oklm*
Un peu.
Bah voilà où sera notre exploitation de bière.
Elle descendra en même temps que le souterraine.
On aura des nappes phréatiques de bières , mon pote.
Le 2ème bar, on manque de consommateurs et on manque de vent frais p**ain !
Ajouter des chênes, ah là-haut c'est vraiment le dépôt.
Voilà le vent frais c'est réglé.
Maintenant ce qu'il nous faut c'est.. plus d'appart.
Hop-là ! (x3)
Là il y a du consommateur mon pote.
Mec... je crois... que je viens d'avoir une idée exceptionnelle.
On recommence à zéro, regardez bien.
1ère étape : on fait un étage complet de sol.
Comme ça on aura jamais de problèmes d'eau de m**de là.
Ok. L' avantage sur le sens, c'est qu'on peut construire ce qu'on veut parce que... c'est du sol.
Je reprends à zéro parce que, c'est important je pense de déjà
produire tout ce qu'il faut avant de se mettre à ramener des gens et tout.
Sinon après c'est la m**de. Tu construis une habitation, tu construis un arbre, ça n'a plus aucun sens.
On a nos apparts là, ça c'est le coin ressources.
Pour le moment, tout est suffisant sauf l'argent parce qu'il va falloir commencer à ouvrir des épiceries.
Pourquoi ça ne me fait pas de... de... de consommateurs là ?
Ah mais m**de ! Je les empêche de sortir de leurs maisons !
A cause des... des... Oh le con !
Pardon de vous avoir enfermés ! Désolé (x3)
C'est terrible ce que j'ai fait. Terrible !
Les amis j'ai dû modifier, ici j'ai dû retirer un étage du sol pour mettre des apparts.
Voilà les gens y ont accès via l'ascenseur, qui part de là pour aller à l'étage. C'est très très bien ce qu'on a fait.
On ne génère pas de thune, mais ce n'est pas grave parce qu'on va faire le 1er bar de l'endroit.
Ce qu'on va faire c'est très simple, 4 champs de blé et bien sûr, de la brasserie.
Une fois que ceci est fait, on va mettre un bar qui va générer des millions d'euros
Padin !
Incroyable !
Bon clairement, c'est là où tout va se jouer voir si, tout ce que je veux faire ça marche ou pas.
Est-ce que ça marche ?
*Moment de suspense*
OUI !!
L'étage est créé !!
P**ain mec c'est génial.
Ici on a la liste des habitants et on peut voir ce qu'ils aiment.
Bailey est un client, qu'est-ce qu'il aime Bailey ?
Il aime les données et il aime les médias.
Il est c*n.
Bruce : il aime les fruits et il aime les légumes.
Bruce, t'es un gars bien.
Oh un marché ! Il faut des légumes et du poisson.
Ferme de légumes, je crois que c'est exactement ce qu'on cherchait.
Je viens de créer ma petite ferme aquatique qui va me faire mon poisson.
Je fais maintenant ma petite ferme hydroponique qui va me faire mes légumes.
On a plus qu'à faire le marché !
Tada !
P**ain, je suis trop content, j'ai réussi à vraiment euh.. à créer ma petite ville ici là.
Même si cet appart avec vue sur le sol est un peu ghetto.
J'ai des thunes, on va gagner en électricité pour pouvoir faire de grandes choses.
On va mettre 2 générateurs mon pote.
Et mais mec, je suis en train de construire un empire c'est un truc de ouf !
Franchement, on est trop bien. Je sais, je.. j'ai trop d'électricité, je ne sais plus quoi faire.
Je ne sais plus quoi faire, tout va trop bien.
AH !!! On va ouvrir la ville au tourisme mon gars bien sûr !
Hôtel Formule 1, il fait de l'eau chaude et des touristes.
Ok on va résoudre ce problème tout de suite.
Chauffe eau solaire, il y a pas un chauffe eau genre qui bombarde plus tu sais ?
Bon alors on va mettre le chauffe eau solaire un peu nul.
Est-ce qu'on peut le mettre là ?
Mais oui !! Par dessus les générateurs c'est incroyable ce qu'on est en train de faire.
Le chauffe-eau c'est fait.
Les touristes seront bien et ils pourront se faire chauffer les pieds.
Encore faut-il qu'il y ait des touristes. Comment j'attire des touristes ici ?
AH !! Un néon publicitaire ! Voilà ce qui attire ces p**ains de touristes.
Il y a rien d'autres qui peut attirer des touristes ? Un truc mieux qu'un néon poster dégueulasse, ça n'existe pas ?
AH ! Si, un obélisque ! Mais bien sûr c'est évident !
Obélisque.
Est-ce que du coup, les touristes arrivent ?
Il est l'heure d'ouvrir le 1er hôtel, de la Squeezie City !
Padin din !!!! Pa la la pin pin !
C'est tout ? Et attends c'est quoi cet hôtel ?
Mon gars l'hôtel on dirait une machine à laver. Nickel !
Et bien voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur... J'ai pas oublié le nom !
Je ne suis pas du tout en train de faire un retour Windows, c'est Black.. "Black'Hood" il s'appelle ouais.
J'espère que cela vous aura plu ! N'hésitez pas à aimer comme d'habitude !
Et p**ain c'est un jeu, mec il est hyper cool c'est génial et, c'est complexe quoi.
Enfin les mecs n'ont pas fait les choses à moitié. Ils ont vraiment poussé le truc à fond.
Tout à l'heure, j'ai commencé à enregistrer la vidéo pour la petite histoire
et au bout de 10 minutes, j'ai fait : Nan mais attends je ne comprends rien, ça ne va pas du tout !
Faut que je fasse le tuto, j'ai un cerveau trop nul !
Et les reviews Steam disaient ça qu'au début tu te fais un peu chier tu ne comprends pas trop.
Et dès que tu commences à bien emboîter tout, c'est vraiment bien.
Voilà. Si vous n'avez pas quitté la vidéo, sous ces explications relous,
je vous remercie en vous chantant Stromae.
(Papaoutai de Stromae : Squeezie Cover)
(Sous-titres par : Rhynn)